the following trailer is rated s for
spoilers
[Music]
in a cinematic universe known for its
huge casts CGI and mixed-up timelines
and x-men movie will rise above its
peers by saying that we're doing our own
thing Logan wow that didn't put x-men or
Wolverine the title you're getting some
big cojones these days Fox and I like it
enter a sun-blasted dystopia we're the
last surviving x-men have been screwed
out of their comic book royalties and
ride along with Wolverine once he was a
hero now he's one of those uber drivers
you cancel because it looks like he's
going to murder you Hugh Jackman returns
in his ninth go at the character and the
man who took on Sabretooth Magneto and
silver samurai is fighting all new
villains like bloody coughing feds
fading eyesight you can't read the label
on that bottle
alcoholism claw pus suicidal depression
person shooting myself Mel Gibson facial
hair and the constant urge to nab
and if you think that's depressing
professor X is even older and sadder
than he is maybe you know from Java
I guess it's rated R for realization
that we all get old and die no no no no
no no no everything will change when
Logan meets his clone daughter Laura a
miniature version of Wolverine and
Espanyol's
together Logan and Charles will drive
her to the Lost Boys clubhouse in North
Dakota and that's it
wait I thought all x-men movies had to
cram in the Phoenix saga time travel to
recast someone I mean whose side is
mystique even on in this movie they
don't even bust through a fence after
someone says hold on
that never happens the mutants of the
United States have been wiped out by
corn or something shopping at Columbus
now thrill as the last remaining Mexican
ones are hunted across America by a man
named Donald and a cyborg doing his best
impression of Val Kilmer in Tombstone
The Wolverine
and looking for someone who's learn
about his evil plan from Laura's
guardian a nurse and the best cellphone
documentary maker ever by the ocean
there's like 50 different shots in this
thing I mean check out that audio
quality what does she do write a
voiceover booth they could not be
controlled who's even holding the camera
man iMovie must be sick in the future so
enjoy Hugh Jackman's final performance
as Wolverine that makes the last 17
years of x-men movies look mad by
comparison and even pays off the
prophecy from the Wolverine I saw your
die you're hoarding your own heart in
your head see cuz Laura's holding his
head Jesus heart you know and uh Dan
this movies hard to make fun of I gotta
call in some help
let's see Michael Bolton mister
good oh here we go Yello hey Deadpool
buddy it's honest trailers whoo good one
no seriously who is this I have you
saved his fat Betsy don't pick up
not sure why I picked up so we're live
right now in the middle of our 200th
honest trailer for Logan and we were
having trouble was hoping we could call
you for something edgy or mean to say
mm-hmm are you high I'm not gonna log in
that film is a being masterpiece if
Jackman doesn't get an Oscar nom I'm
setting every VHS copy of crash on fire
you're not threatened by another already
at superhero movie full of violence and
cursing where the hero lives with a
senior and as a kick-ass girl sidekick
huh oh you mother first
you're not gonna bait me into this I do
the baiting around here mister I do not
endorse this weak attempt to take down
the jack man just a goose your views
it's not my fault YouTube keeps
unsubscribing people without telling
them but I do endorse James mangle to
make old man Deadpool in 2038 oh how
good would that be just 90 minutes a
cable and I changing each other's space
diapers that sounds terrible and what
would you know fat Betsy this is exactly
why I don't take your calls anymore a
good day sir
oh wait please let me be an able to AH
starring Logan's Run the Nutty Professor
snikt girl young man Logan steampunk
Colonel Sanders Bex men first class and
Joey
The Last of Us New Mutants a young one
they won't help
there are no New Moon's Fox would like a
word with you thanks to special guest
Ryan Reynolds and thanks for your
support and getting us to 200 trailers
seriously
make sure you've clicked the subscribe
button and the little bell icon below
epic voice guy can't get it up without
the pews if you want more laughs check
out our new show flick bait featuring
all the guys behind the honest trailers
it's free every Friday live at 4 p.m.
Pacific Standard Time click the I card
and the upper right to watch now ooh new
YouTube features you were beautiful on
the inside can you can a can as a canner
can can a can the coldest blood runs
through my veins you know my name the
Transformers and Twilight franchises are
the best movie franchises made in
history like ever
the Krusty Krab pizza is the pizza for
you and me